it's November and that means another
monthly batch of free games for
PlayStation Plus subscribers if you want
to know what you can be thankful for
this month I've got you covered
and if you're sad about leaving
Halloween behind you'll want to pay
extra attention to this one
first up ps4 is getting worms
battlegrounds not to be confused with
player unknowns battlegrounds this game
is all about little worms blowing each
other up with all sorts of weapons it
makes for some pretty cartoonishly
violent multiplayer ps4 is also getting
bound this unique platformer is about
literally dancing your way through
childhood memories across a bunch of
trippy highly stylized levels and you
can always stop to take a photo of the
imaginative landscapes if something
catches your eye but wait there's more
in celebration of PlayStation VR
one-year anniversary you can also grab
until dawn rush of blood this spin-off
isn't about making dialogue choices for
a bunch of teens it's a shooting gallery
where you're strapped into a crazy
bloody rollercoaster unlike the rest of
these games it'll be available until
January 2nd on the ps3 side you can get
your hands on our type dimensions this
is a compilation of our type 1 & 2 and
if you're unfamiliar with the staple
side-scrolling shooter here's the
elevator pitch spaceships aliens and
lots of lasers ps3 players can also try
out ragdoll kung fu as the name implies
this is a fighting game but you don't
just control a bunch of martial artists
you control their individual limbs and
other body parts if you're able to wrap
your head around that you can also take
the battles online as for the Vita
you'll get both episodes of Broken Sword
5 the Serpent's curse the adventure game
is a good fit given the Vita's
touchscreen and an optional hint system
means you won't have to just poke around
until you click on the right solution
finally the Vita is also getting dungeon
punks think old-school beat them up but
with some RPG mechanics special attacks
per character and a rad art style thanks
to cross buy you can also try this one
out on ps4 and those are your free PS
plus games for November they'll be
available starting
Tuesday November 7th through December
5th you can always check out gameplay
clips and reviews for these titles on
GameSpot and if you want to keep up with
all of our top stories you can grab the
official game spot now app on iOS and
Android
[Music]
you